pierre moscovici commissaire européen
aux affaires économiques et financières
est avec nous bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation donc
pour répondre
comme chaque semaine dans preuve par 3 à
3 grandes questions premièrement l'union
européenne face à une avalanche de crise
joue aujourd'hui sa dernière chance
c'est vous qui le dites alors peut-elle
échapper à l'explosion vous nous le dira
et deuxième question la commission
européenne n'affiche pas le même
optimisme pas tout à fait un et que
paris sur la croissance et la baisse du
déficit l'objectif étant d'arriver enfin
aux 3% déficit en 2017 mais le
gouvernement
on le voit qu'ils signent des chèques et
le chef de l'état qui envisage des
baisses d'impôts joue-t-il avec le feu
par manque de sérieux vous le dirai tout
à l'heure à lucile malandain de l'
agence france-presse
enfin troisième question françois
hollande a convoqué aujourd'hui les
mânes de la gauche à ses deux jours
anniversaires avec 80e anniversaire du
front populaire
mais peut-il encore l'incarner quand le
sentiment de trahison semble dominer
aujourd'hui un chez les électeurs de
gauche et chez beaucoup d'élus également
vous répondrai tout à l'heure à perrine
tarneaud de public sénat
mes premières questions donc à moscovici
l'union européenne joue ten sa survie
aujourd'hui vous parler de sa dernière
chance
oui c'est vrai que nous sommes
confrontés un nombre de crise absolument
sans précédent on dit toujours que
l'europe progresse dans les crises c'est
vrai enfin là vous avez la crise des
réfugiés qui est quand même une crise
absolument existentielle vous avez la
menace terroriste vous avez la tente
dans laquelle nous sommes
du référendum sur le break site vous
avez la crise grecque qui mobilise suis
négociateur pour la commission
européenne d'un accord avec la grèce qu
elle souhaite parvenir à trouver
on est vraiment dans la semaine qui
vient avec des incertitudes donc dans un
bourg un pays qui perd y aurait frappé
par une terrible crise humanitaire avec
tiré devant et il ya la crise économique
et de crise humanitaire il ya le besoin
de conclure ce programme et enfin il ya
toujours la crise économique et sociale
elle n'est plus là j'ai donné ce matin
les prévisions de croissance de
printemps de la commission européenne
nous sommes dans la quatrième année de
reprise maintenant la croissance est
installé le chômage recule jamais on en
reparlera en reparler fier s'équilibre
mais les défis mais tout de même les
deux équipes sociaux sont puissants et
quand vous avez des taux de chômage qui
continue d'être supérieure à 10% dans la
zone euro et vite
a man ça crée une instabilité et tout ça
débouche sur une menace commune à nos
démocraties nas de du populisme la
montée des extrêmes et en particulier
extrême droite
le repli sur soi et quand je vois madame
le pen avoir comme slogan non à l'union
européenne
et oui à la france je me dis que là on
est dans le contresens absolu parce que
la france est au coeur de l'europe parce
que l'europe et la france c'est la même
chose parce que l'europe n'est pas une
politique extérieure une politique
étrangère et et je me dis qu il y a un
défi commun qui est de combattre les
populistes et je me dis aussi c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis là qu'il
faut que les pro-européens et sortent de
leur timidité n'est pas leurs pondeuses
et l'europe fier et surtout propose des
solutions parce que hope l'un des défis
que j'ai énoncé n'a de solution
européenne
on va rester d'abord sur marine le pen
puisque vous l'évoquez aujourd'hui c'est
assez rare angela merkel s'exprime
rarement sur la politique intérieure
française
elle dit qu'elle va s'engager pour
lutter contre le front national est ce
que c'est une démarche bienvenue de sa
part s'agit pas commenter le fait de
sorcier bienvenue parce que je sais ce
que je sais vous avez dénoncé ce que je
sarine le psg là vous avez l'allier et
la merkel je sais pour aller souvent à
berlin c'est à quel point la montée des
extrêmes en france mais aussi maintenant
en allemagne avec l'afd angoisse nous
amis allemands
il ya chez eux une mémoire collective
qui de mémoire des années 30 il ya
surtout une culpabilité ou en tout cas
le désir que ne recommence jamais les
atroces dérives qui ont amené au nazisme
et il y a la conviction qu'il faut tout
faire par l'europe pour que jamais on
retrouve la menace du nationaliste
grecque un disait mitterrand
oui le nationalisme c'est la guerre
comment on gagne à dire qu'elle peut
contribuer à ce combat contre le front
national aujourd'hui en faisait lanvaux
en faisant en sorte que l'europe soit
une europe forte
ancré dans ses valeurs il s'agit pas
pour elle j'imagine de s'immiscer dans
le débat politique à dessel et en appui
des policiers ce qui si lutte contre le
fn c'est ce qu'elle dit on verra comment
elle fait mais je ne crois pas que ce
soit tellement ça mais c'est surtout
faire en sorte de convaincre à nouveau
que l'europe et la réponse est la
solution
et je pense que si elle fait ça c'est
aussi parce qu'elle voit que les
populismes justement ne sont pas un
privilège triste privilège français elle
voit qu'en autriche 3 1 et voit qu'aux
triche à la présidentielle au premier
tour le candidat il faudra fait 35% elle
voit life des montées et enfants que je
pense qu'il est nécessaire en effet que
les pro européens agissent et pourquoi
pas ensemble moi de ce point de vue je
ne suis pas totalement choqués ou je ne
suis pas choqué parce que je pense que
il y à des valeurs communes que nous
devons défendre
il ya des combats européen ou
paneuropéen il ya des partis qui sont
des partis européens
il ya des valeurs qui sont des valeurs
européennes je suis contre un combat
européen contre le front national en
france à un combat européen contre le
populisme dont la femme française et le
front national
oui et de la même façon que pour ma part
je surveille de près ce qui se passe
dans d'autres pays d'europe si les
britanniques à la fin du mois de juin
vote la sortie de l'union européenne est
ce que là ça ne va pas être une
incroyable opportunité pour marine le
pen qui l'a pourrait sans doute faire
exploser son fameux plafond de verre est
ce que c'est votre crainte c'est
peut-être son rêve raveonettes mais mes
jeux de l'es22 de réponse à la première
c'est que j'ai le souhait et j'ai la
conviction que le royaume uni restera
dans une europe unie parce que c'est
l'intérêt du royaume uni parce que c'est
l'intérêt de l'europe parce que toute
autre solution serait perdante pour les
uns est perdante pour les autres et donc
ça ne se produira pas la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il n'aura pas échappé
marie le pen comme tout le monde que le
rugby n'était pas la france
nous nous sommes un pays fondateur de
l'union européenne nous nous sommes un
pays pour laquelle pour lequel la
construction européenne a été construite
c'est bien la réconciliation
franco-allemande qui est là il nous
enfin nous sommes un pays coeur de la
zone euro nous avons non seulement en
commun c'est pas une europe en version
dévoilée en internat aussi l'euro et les
français dont je vois vraiment avec
inquiétude la montée du sentiment
eurosceptique chez eux
les français savent que le rôle et
protège et les défend et les français
sont attachés
quand on regarde les paramètres on le
voit attachés à l'euro dont marine le
pen se trompent les français ne voteront
jamais contre l'europe les français
n'iront jamais
pour une sortie de l'euro ce que nous
devons faire nous les pro-européens
c'est simplement mieux montrer en quoi
il y a des solutions européennes qui
sont positives pour les citoyens de ce
pays
pierre moscovici vous évoquez les vertus
également les valeurs de l'union va
parler des migrants il y a des mots très
durs qui sont prononcés aujourd'hui par
exemple nicolas hulot qui s'est dit dans
le monde
écoeurés par je le cite l'immobilisme
crasse de l'europe face aux milliers de
noyer qu'est ce que vous lui répondait
d'abord qu'il se trompe complètement un
mois je suis membre de la commission
européenne nous nous réunissons tous les
mercredis on se dira à nouveau demain
matin on aura par exemple à traiter
d'une question qui est celle des visas
pour la turquie
une des conditions sans doute de la
bonne application d'un accord écriture
qui permet de limiter les flux de
réfugiés
la commission est composée d'un accord
je pense que c'était un accord
nécessaire qu'il faut faire fonctionner
et qui effectivement produit déjà de
premiers résultats et les mêlées fameux
visa pour les plus aucun décret du
chanteur nous en parlerons démarre il
faut qu'il y ait des critères objectifs
et la commission est en train de les
examiner
je n'ai pas moins à faire ce commentaire
la décision sera prise demain et donc je
vous demande à tous de patience par
rapport à ça on doit être par rapport à
la turquie et à la fois dans une
attitude de coopération nécessaire mais
aussi dans une attitude de fermeté sur
les principes et d'attachement à
certaines valeurs je pense par exemple à
la liberté de la presse qui est
totalement inaliénable inattaquable
j'étais en turquie il ya une semaine et
je les dis à l'après surgelés dis à mes
amis tueur mais en même temps c'est un
pays qui est démocratique avec lequel il
faut coopérer notamment sur cette crise
de réfugiés mais pas seulement qui est
aussi un important partenaire économique
mais est ce que c'est un pays qui a
vocation à entrer dans l'union un jour
pour vous cette appli candidats l'union
européenne mon sentiment c'est que quand
on est un candidat dôme négociations de
bonne foi et que cette question pourrait
se poser un jour mais quand je dis un
jour c'est dans un jour très longtemps
très loin et très lointain c'est tout à
fait hypothétique
encore faut-il que toutes les conditions
pour c'est à dire soit réunie
aujourd'hui à lévis dans l air elles ne
sont pas et ne seront pas dit ou pas de
sitôt alors sur cet accord un essai
comme et leur nez les eaux mais pour
autant il est important que la
négociation soit conduite de bonne foi
ce qui veut dire que à terme à 15 ans à
20 ans la porte peut être ouverte si
nous sommes capables justement de
dessiner
un arc de valeurs de principes et
d'intérêts communs temps alors c'est pas
pour ne sais pas pourquoi c'est pas de
sitôt je sais peut-être d'ailleurs pour
jamais en tout le potez le rapprochement
entre l'europe et la turquie le
rapprochement et la coopération sont
indispensables mais vous me demandiez ce
que faisait l'europe soulevez-vous
interrogé sur l'accord parce qu'il est
donc très critiquée avec la colle à
l'europe
je veux y assister une réponse vraiment
global sur la crise des réfugiés
nous disons 1 comme madame merkel et moi
j'approuve son courage sur ce sujet je
lui dis que je pense qu'à genève les
alliances que je pense qu'elle était
confrontée à la plus deux millions de
réfugiés et qu'elle eut le courage de
dire que quand des hommes et des femmes
sont menacées dans leur vie par des
régimes qui sont des régimes
sanguinaires qui les prive de toute
liberté il faut savoir les accueillir
moi quand je suis né et ce n'est pas que
je suis né je suis né mon père était
réfugié et donc l'accueil de réfugiés
oui ça fait partie des valeurs
humanistes de l'union par l'autriche a
dompté par un visage même de supprimer
la notion d'asile
à damas des réfugiés c'est la raison
pour laquelle il est important que des
accords comme celui qui est passé
culture qu'ils soient mis en place parce
que ça permet justement de dire voilà il
ya des migrants qui doivent pas entrer
chez nous il ya des réfugiés qui doivent
entrer chez nous et qui doivent être
réalloués ensuite il faut protéger nos
frontières et enfin il faut intégrer
ceux qui ont vocation à rester
légalement dans le marché du travail
écoutez le sénateur communiste michel
billaut sur cette question il réagi à
cet accord donc est entrée en vigueur
avec la turquie et qui ferme une route
si on ferme une route sans régler le
problème de fond
aujourd'hui on a des centaines de
milliers de personnes qui fuient la
guerre qui fuient la famine les
emprunteront d'autres routes parfois
peut-être plus longue et plus dangereuse
on a vu effectivement un nouveau
naufrage se produire dans les eaux de la
mer méditerranée avec 300 km de mer à
franchir pour atteindre d'hypothétiques
côtes italiennes donc effectivement si
l'efficacité de cet accord c'est de
déplacer le problème et de le rendre
encore plus dangereux il ira sans doute
que des recommandations de notre part
peut-être pour traiter les choses
autrement
des critiques d'ordre humanitaire mais
des critiques de fond également de la
part du sénateur michel billaut
rencontrer tout à l'heure par faustine
saint-geniès puisqu'une autre route
pourrait s'ouvrir demain
déjà il est important tout de même que
cette route ci soient maîtrisés
contrôler et puis c'est pas seulement ça
parce qu'il ya non seulement un accord
ou ferment cette route ou si on ouvre un
autre canal qui est l'accueil de
réfugiés qui leur seraient installés
être réalloués dans nos pays mais là où
il a raison et là où nicolas hulot a
raison je dis il a tort de penser que
l'europe n'a pas de réponse mais il a
raison sur un point c'est que cette
réponse doit être humaniste et
humanitaire ce qui veut dire qu'il faut
être capable de protéger nos frontières
je crois pas l'une des propositions de
la commission qui verra le jour la
création d'un corps de gardes côtes ou
de gardes frontières parce que notre
frontière commune doit être protégé mais
il est important aussi de lutter contre
ces modernes négriers ces hommes qui
exploitent la détresse de ceux qui
fuient leur pays qu'ils le font à prix
d'or et qui se trouvent la mort en mer
et donc ça ça implique aussi que nos
forces nos forces maritimes soient
renforcés c'est une réponse globale que
nous voulons articulé également dans
l'actualité l'avenir du traité
transatlantique vous suivez également ce
dossier de près après les révélations
hier de greenpeace 5 et kiki un peu
percer le voile sur ces négociations
très opaque 1 qui dure depuis des des
années eh bien la france sonne la charge
aujourd'hui vous l'avez noté
c'est non à ce stade pour françois
hollande et on écoute matthias fekl le
secrétaire d'état au commerce extérieur
eh ben il y lit également la même chose
bien sûr est un accord qui tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui
est ce serait un mauvais accord sur tous
les sujets que vous avez indiquée et je
l' ai déjà dit j'ai été le seul membre
d'un gouvernement dès 2015 a tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé et à dire ça ne va pas
et si les choses continuent comme ça les
négociations doivent s'arrêter alors
donc ses détracteurs dénoncent un traité
dangereux parce que donc il va rester un
certain nombre de normes notamment entre
l'europe et les états unis
est ce que vous vous intégrez inquiétés
de la tournure des événements pierre
moscovici avec cette france aujourd'hui
qui veut manifestement entraver les
négociations alors simone et 30 secondes
1 je considère que le principe d'une
négociation commerciale entre les états
unis et l'europe ne doit pas être
écartée car cela peut être d'intérêt
commun un bon type nous permettrait
permettrait à l'europe de s'ouvrir les
marchés américains et soyons conscients
que les marchés américains sont
aujourd'hui plus fermé que les marchés
européens donc je ne dis pas fermons la
négation et c'est pas bien sûr ensuite
je les dis il faut que ce soit un bon
type
aujourd hui nous n'avons pas d'accord
nous avons des négociations qui ne sont
pas si opaque que ça d'ailleurs à la
commission veille
est ce que tous les états membres soient
informés au fur et à mesure de la façon
d'un jeu et ma collègue notamment 7e as
rome seront très souvent devant le
parlement vers naturellement il ya une
information qui est fait mais
aujourd'hui il faut que cette
négociation progresse et elle n'est pas
un stade qui permettent de conclure un
accord un car cela a été dit et par
françois hollande et par matthias fekl
et par d'autres
nous ne voulons pas d'une d'un accord
qui compromettrait aux normes
environnementales qui comprennent rien
aux normes sanitaires qui mettrait en
cause l'existence de notre agriculture
ou qu'ils ne permettraient pas l'accès
aux marchés publics
voilà un certain nombre de conditions
donc sur le principe nous opposons pas
la négociation de tête conduite de
manière extrêmement serré et solide en
fonction de nos intérêts stratégie est
ce que c'est possible aujourd'hui est ce
que là est ce que les états unis ne
cherchent pas à imposer leur point de
vue et l'aciériste ne cherche pas comme
disent les détracteurs à mettre l'europe
sous tutelle moi j'ai pris un petit peu
de recul avec certaines passions
nationales et j'imagine que si j'étais
amérique
je voyais le document européen je me
dirais non européens
ils ont plein les yeux rougis ne veulent
pas nous aider ne nous comprennent pas
c'est le propre d'une négociation et
donc moi je suis pas très choqué par le
fait que aujourd'hui les deux parties ne
soit pas vraiment en train de se
rencontrer mais on risque d'affaiblir
l'europe je sais ce premier point
n'avance le principe ne l'écartons pas
deuxième fois il faut un bon type il
faut beaucoup de conditions et troisième
point ces conditions aujourd'hui ne sont
pas remplies la question qui est devant
nous c'est la question du temps parce
qu'elle va se peut de temps pour
conclure éventuellement se titille
puisque vous savez que l'administration
américaine est celle de barack obama
s'achève début novembre
donc voilà le compte à rebours est très
serré et quand le président dit
aujourd'hui ce serait non
je suis d'accord aujourd'hui on n'y est
pas je le dire différemment mais il faut
en même temps que la négociation se
poursuivre que le travail soit sage en
tous les cas ne crois pas un barack
obama qui en fin de mandat vous l'avez
rappelé mais il faut mener une
négociation très serré très conscients
nous intérêt de tous propres lignes
rouges très ferme un bon type ou pas de
type
voilà c'est avec ces attentions aussi
est très très très ferme ce que barack
obama a rendu visite à l'europe
il ya quelques jours il est allé à
hanovre en allemagne où il a tenu un
discours pro européen qui a marqué et la
même l'ancien un appel au sursaut on
l'écoutent fo you'll find puis si une
europe unie pacifiquement démocratique
failli marquer bio
big-m stone town est sauf et orientée
vers l'économie de marché commence à
douter d'elle-même
beggen stocks croissants à remettre en
question les progrès réalisés ces
dernières décennies on voit se servant
de la grèce alors nous ne pouvons
espérer que le progrès qui commence tout
juste à prendre place dans tellement
d'endroits à travers le monde continue
est-ce que ce discours vibrant de barack
obama n'a pas soigné finalement que
l'europe est en panne de deux dirigeants
visionnaires et engagé c'est ce que
j'aime c'est un cri dont l'express avait
un commentaire d'un livre de jacques
donation j'attendais d'eux le sa part
peut-être venir des initiatives fortes à
dire que vous risquez aussi françois
hollande absent première chose je vais y
venir après si vous permettez première
chose on a besoin de voix fortes
éventuellement venant de l'extérieur
comme celle du président des états unis
pour nous rappeler ce qu'est l'europe
l'europe ce n'est pas qu'un marchandage
d'intérêt l'europe ce n'est pas un
problème l'europe c'est une solution
l'europe ce sont des valeurs est d'abord
l'europe c'est une communauté
démocratique et économique qui était
construite pour faire vivre la paix et
vous savez quand je regarde la
physionomie de ce continent
je vois aujourd'hui la montée des
nationalismes et le nationalisme est une
menace
souvenons nous qu'en même ayant un peu
de mémoire historique sur ce qui s'est
passé dans les années 30
aujourd'hui c'est loin c'est loin
derrière et c'est loin devant mais ne
faisons pas comme s'il n'y avait pas des
menaces vraiment existentielle
dramatique quand je parlais de dernière
chance de l'europe c'est de chalonge pas
et donc le président des états unis
il a raison de nous rappeler pourquoi
nous avons fait l'europe
ensuite il est vrai que vivre ensuite
c'est vrai que pour que l'europe avance
il faut une commission qui soit active
celle ci l'est je pense que la
commission bancaire est la plus active
depuis la commission delors cachemiris
95 et il faut c'est vrai des dirigeants
visionnaires et engagé et il faut en
particulier sont pas là un tandem
franco-allemand qui soit harmonieux qui
soit équilibrée et qui est de l'avant et
quand je disais que j'attends du
président de répliques qui prennent
l'initiative c'est parce que nous sommes
confrontés à une telle série de crises
pensez vous que je pense par une carte
efforts du président une parole faite en
dur
j'ai cru noter tout à l'heure qui devait
faire un discours genou gauche on va en
parler quelle il avait annoncé lui même
qu'après le référendum pour ou contre le
braque site
il aurait à parler pour dire quoi pour
dire quel est le chemin quel chemin pour
l'europe entière pour l'europe avec le
royaume uni
c'est à la fois mon souhait est ma
conviction mais aussi le chemin pour la
zone euro parce que autant je souhaite
que le royaume uni reste dans l'union
européenne
autant je pense que les pays qui ont en
commun l'euro doivent aller plus loin
plus loin dans leur intégration
politique plus loin dans leur
intégration économique
je suis retiré je ne pas resserrer le
coeur de l'europe c'est la zone horreur
il faut que le carnage ne reçoit plus
fort battre plus fort aujourd'hui on a
construit une romy est une union
monétaire
il nous manque encore l'union économique
et l'union politique c'est la raison
pour laquelle moi je propose amis de
l'économie et des finances de la zone
euro qui serait membre de la commission
responsable devant le parlement européen
avec un budget pour la zone euro qui
permettent d'investir
vous souhaitez être au chômage dès qu'un
trésor de la zone euro il y a beaucoup
de propositions à faire ce sont toutes
les thèses que vous avez exposé
directement devant françois hollande
hier vous l'avez rencontré vous allez le
voir je vais je mens je le vois tous les
mois c'est un échange qui est à la fois
très professionnel il est prêt lagache
bsr est très amical j'ai fait le sujet
aussi on en parle on en parle tout le
temps il sait ce que je pense et je sais
aussi qu'il a bien attention à faire des
propositions je crois qu'ils osent
annoncé tout à l'heure et elles seront
accueillies avec toute l'importance que
revêt la parole de présents a pu
française une parole français sur
l'europe
il peut y avoir des paroles françaises
mais c'est forcément la parole du
président de la république allait
deuxième partie de preuve parfois
maintenant avec lucid malandain de l'
agence france-presse qui va nous
rejoindre pierre moscovici vous prendrez
à cette question venue de bruxelles la
france joue-t-elle avec le feu par
manque de sérieux
c'est à dire anne en tardant à annoncer
de nouvelles mesures d'économies le
déficit à 3 % en 2017 et bien vous vous
le croyez possible voire probable comme
bercy et mais c'est peut-être un
tropisme le franco français autre
indication du jour à commission se
montre moins optimiste que par bris sur
la croissance l'économiste de l'eau fce
eric heyer rencontrer tout à l'heure par
faustine saint geniès analyse d'ailleurs
la situation de
l'économie aujourd'hui dans notre pays
et que nous française a bénéficié d'un
grand coup de pouce par les éléments
extérieurs prix du pétrole légère baisse
de l'euro taux d'intérêt bas il faut
sans doute mené d'autres réformes
structurelles pour accélérer l'activité
chez même s'il ya une reprise on peut
considérer qu'elle est trop faible trop
molle pour lutter significativement
contre le chômage et donc ses réformes
là c'est sans doute
elles seront menées dans le prochain
quinquennat parce qu'il est très
difficile
en l'espace d'un an de mener des
réformes qui auront une incidence à
court terme
voilà donc ils donnent plutôt
rendez-vous au prochain quinquennat on
l'a entendu bonsoir lucile bonsoir mon
salut donc vous pouvez présenter tout à
l'heure les prévisions de printemps de
la commission européenne les présidents
macroéconomiques
apparemment à nouveau la commission
européenne voit la croissance française
un petit peu moindre que celle qui est
annoncée par le gouvernement
comment pouvez vous expliquer cette
différence ce qui d'abord les cas est
faible nous nous voyons 1,3 le
commandant français voit avec une 5
j'ajoute que nous n'avons pas intégré
dans nos chiffres les résultats du
premier trimestre qui sont plutôt un peu
meilleure que ce qu'elle corporelle nos
propres prévisions
et s'il ya un bonus je dirais tant aux
yeux de toute façon cette croissance de
l'économie française reste légèrement
inférieur à la moyenne de la zone euro
qui devraient de 1,6 pour cent
pour nous cette année et 2,1 des
pensions l'an prochain nous aurions
atteint 8 7% pour la france dont paris
n'a pas à se vanter
il s'agit pas de se vanter ou pas vanté
un peu de positif
si on pose la question de savoir si ça
va mieux puisque c'est un peu du mal à
mode vous dirais que je réponds bien que
ça va plutôt mieux plutôt mieux parce
que vous avez d'une part la croissance
qui est maintenant reparti avec une
consommation intérieure qui tient bon
avec un investissement qui repart et on
attend sans doute le zeste de confiance
supplémentaire
vous avez des finances publiques dont la
situation s'améliore
on y reviendra j'imagine mais oui je
pense tout à fait jouable à condition
que les finances publiques soient
maîtrisées et que les engagements pris
soient respectés
je pense jouable de passer en deçà de 3%
en 2010 est enfin en fin de troisième
chose troisième choses permettez que je
le peux je le jeu l'évoquent parce que
c'est tout à fait important je crois que
le chômage devrait reculer en 2016 de
10,4 pour cent du pib à 10 2% du pib
donc je parle de nous avait prédit la
commission sion aujourd'hui dont une
amélioration une amélioration qui ne
permettra pas de résoudre tous les
problèmes de la société française
notamment sur le chômage
on attend sans doute plus il faudra
continuer mais enfin il quand deux
bonnes nouvelles arrivent il ne faut pas
je pense les négliger non mais là la
commission aujourd'hui danser danser
dans ses prévisions prévoit ne prévoit
pas que la france passera sous la barre
des fameux 3%
je vous rappelle la commission fait beau
je participe à je suis le responsable à
la commission des prévisions aient aussi
nature défensive de la france je vous
expliquais ça on va devenir schizophrène
je suis pas du tout schizophrène ou pas
du tout je suis commissaire est
totalement commissaire je suis par
ailleurs français et totalement pensais
mais je suis mobilisé l'économie mais je
ne veux pas me permettre
et je ne me permet pas la moindre
complaisance à l'égard de mon pays car
si c'était le cas la crédibilité de mon
institution la commission européenne est
la mienne sur immédiatement atteint donc
je vous explique techniquement le lie à
tuer physiquement vous devriez être très
inquiet aujourd'hui je vais vous
expliquer avec les dépenses nouvelles si
on annoncera les éclats vous 2,2 points
premièrement nous donnons 3 2% à
politique inchangée comme on dit en 2017
à politique inchangée ça veut dire que
c'est en ne comptant sur aucun effort
fait dans le budget 2010 j'attendais les
on ne va pas on va pas y arriver si vous
m'interrogez parce que le choix explique
devient un peu plus loin il se trouve
que chaque année la situation des
finances publiques françaises à la fin
d'année et de 0,3 à 0,4 point meilleur
que ce que dit la commission faites le
calcul vous même trois mois 0,3 ou 0,4
ça arrive à 2,9 ou 2,8 par ailleurs nous
allons examiner en 2017 au plus tôt en
2016 le projet de budget pour 2010 est
de la france et nous demanderons
demanderont notamment avec beaucoup de
fermeté que les engagements qui ont été
pris dans le pacte de stabilité soit
tenue ça que ce budget de manière
crédible montre quel est le chemin qui
nous amène en dessous de 3%
est ce que je dis ce n'est pas on va y
arriver je suis pas français à ce point
je ne suis pas schizophrène du doubs je
dis que si il y à des efforts je dis que
si les finances publiques sont sérieuses
je dis que si les dépenses
supplémentaires sur l'équipe avec dc je
dis que si les baisses d'impôts
éventualité reprise en réplique n'a pas
été affirmatif sont financés dans ces
conditions la wii passé de 3,2 en
dessous de 3%
c'est jouable et quand je m'exprime
matière
ma parole personnelle c'est la parole de
la commission je ne veux pas qu'ils
aient une suspicion je suis pas à une
sorte comme ça de le france est
transposée à bruxelles je suis le
commissaire chargé des affaires
économiques et financières
par ailleurs français alors quand je me
lève c'est jouable
c'est ce que pour la commission ne pense
pas que certains ne pensent pas que
c'est fait elle pense que c'est jouable
si la france est sérieuse et vous
demande réelle et sérieuse aujourd'hui
pourquoi vous étiez vous même quand je
compte quand je regarde le chemin car
les décisions l'aller les délinquants on
signe des chèques là mais tous les jours
encore une fois ces chèques c'est que
quand je suis devenu misé finances
j'avais dit à mon prédécesseur
commissaires de la commission fixe les
fins nous nous fixons les moyens je n'ai
pas a expliqué à françois hollande ou à
michel sapin roi manuel valls les choix
qui doit le faire en revanche ce que je
dois faire moi c'est le rappeler qu'il
ya des règles communes et que s'il ya
des dépenses supplémentaires
il devra y avoir des économies
correspondante s'il ya des baisses
d'impôt elles devront être financés
voilà et ça je le rappelle à j'ai posé
plusieurs questions évidemment quand
vous vous étiez vous-même ministre des
finances vous vous plaignez beaucoup à
chaque fois qu'il y avait les prévisions
de printemps et d'automne de la
commission européenne que justement la
commission européenne ne tiennent pas
compte des réformes qui allaient être
faites et passer son temps à finalement
tapé sur les doigts des états membres et
notamment de la france en disant vous
n'arriverez pas à vos 3 % 2017 comme
promis
comment expliquez-vous aujourd'hui que
passer de l'autre côté du miroir
vous faites un peu la même chose qu'un
le message qui est passé aujourd'hui
j'adore par la commission européenne ce
et on n'arrivera pas à 3% en 2010 un
premier temps vous me reprocher d'être
au point d'une jambe comme je n'ai pas
changé
les séances aussi que je ne suis pas du
tout schizophrène j'ai toujours pensé
que nous étions nous la france je suis
français dans un espace européen
nous avons choisi avec des règles qui
ont été votées par les parlements et que
nous devons appliquer est ce que je
demande c'est que ce soit fait de
manière convenable
autrement dit ça n'est pas à la
commission d'entrer dans le détail de la
machine et de dire vous devez faire si
vous devez faire ça c'est insupportable
et si on veut que marine le pen
finissent par gagner faisons le budget
de la france à bruxelles
fusent est ce que c'est ça l'image
qu'elle donne aujourd'hui en disant on
arrivera pas autrement encore une fois
que dit elle elle dit à politique
inchangée nous sommes à 3,2 avec des
efforts supplémentaires
nous serons aisément en dessous de 3%
les mêmes conditions que ceux des ports
soient vraies et donc encore une fois
quand je suis dans mon rôle je rappelle
la règle
je rappelle les engagements de la france
je demande à la france de tenir des
engagements de son programme de
stabilité et si cela se fait c'est tant
mieux
nous nous rencontrerons alors les fins
commune c'est à dire les 3 % et les
règles communes seront respectés et les
moyens ont été choisis par le bilan
français il aura fait les dépenses qu'il
veut il aura fait les baisses d'impôts
qu'il veut mais il les aura financé et
donc c'est bien les balises des travaux
qu'il peut l'accord est ce que vous
redoutez que le gouvernement il ya une
pression avec une partie de sa majorité
renonce à la dernière tranche de du
pacte de responsabilité qui profite aux
entreprises là et il y aurait des
économies genou et comme je ne vais pas
me prononcer là dessus ce que je peux
dire simplement c'est que ce qui est
important c'est que la france conserve
sa compétitivité et je peux aller plus
loin là pour le coup à titre personnel
je pense que quand on a mis en place le
pack de conte de responsabilité nous
partions d'une analyse de la
compétitivité française qui était trop
faible et que une politique pro
entreprise dans ce pays est une
politique nécessaire pour permettre que
la confiance reparte et que
l'investissement reparte et donc je
pense qu'il faut autant que possible
tenir ses engagements là pourquoi parce
que ce sont les entreprises qui créent
de la valeur ajoutée sont les
entreprises qui créent de l'emploi sont
les entreprises qui créent de la
richesse ça veut pas dire que ça doit
être fait sans contrepartie se veut pas
dire qu' il ne faut pas s'assurer de ce
que deviennent ces milliards d'euros
mais encore une fois une politique pro
compétitivité n'était nécessaire en 2012
elle reste nécessaire en 2006 c'est
clair voilà alors écoutez bruno le maire
candidat à la primaire de la droite il
veut dit-il baissé lui les dépenses de
90 milliards d'euros un certain candidat
de droite met le curseur beaucoup plus
haut lors du prochain quinquennat et il
plaide pour la stabilité fiscale
les entrepreneurs ont été tellement
échaudés nos partenaires étrangers ont
été tellement échaudés par les
changements permanents de cap
la vie politique française qu'il faut
leur donner le garantie absolue de
stabilité notre fiscalité
j'inscrirai le principe de stabilité
fiscale dans la constitution
j'ai déposé en 2012 avec mon amie
valérie pécresse une proposition de loi
en ce sens que je reprendrai si j'étais
élu président de la république en 2017
et il a été ministre en 2012 que je
prends non mais on verra ce que
choisissent les français on dit toujours
que franchement demain ce sera différent
dire que le maire évoque la stabilité
fiscale françois hollande tout à l'heure
a donc laissé entendre qu'il pourrait y
avoir si c'était possible une nouvelle
baisse d'impôts
ce serait la quatrième depuis le début
de son quinquennat
vous avez bien connu l'époque du
ras-le-bol fiscale puisque vous étiez à
bercy à ce moment-là vous même ces
notions de vos amis qu'est ce que est ce
que vous pensez que cette nouvelle
baisse d'impôts et raisonnable et est ce
que vous pensez globalement que
c'est toutes ces différentes annonces
qui ont été faites depuis janvier y
compris aujourd'hui même une
augmentation pour les professeurs des
écoles qui doit être fait par valsecchi
est assez conséquente
est ce que ça ne ressemble pas à des
cadeaux pré électoraux comme aucun
événement général voulons c'est ni sur
les dépenses ni sur les baisses d'impôts
ça c'est des choix politiques sont
chauds nationaux la seule chose qui
m'importe à moi c'est qu'au final cette
politique soit équilibré qu'elle
permette de respecter nos règles et
devenir ans à 3 %
mais puisque vous avez évoqué le
ras-le-bol fiscale je me souvient en
effet que quand j'ai dit que les
français éprouvait un sentiment de
ras-le-bol fiscale c'était à l'été 2013
j'ai été critiqué
j'ai dû quitter par certains de mes amis
politiques comme quoi la post est
formidable c'est nécessaire aux services
publics
je le pense toujours il faut des impôts
pour financer des services publics en
même temps une bonne fiscalité je suis
aussi commissaire à la fiscalité
c'est une fiscalité qui simple c'est une
fiscalité dont compréhensible par les
citoyens d'une fiscalité qui n'est pas
confiscatoire et c'est enfin une
fiscalité qui est favorable à la
compétitivité parce que c'est ce qu'il
faut pour l'emploi comme disait turgot
ou le regretté guerre fort que vous
connaissez que moi michel grossiord
originaire d'une région que je connais
c'est un grand tort que d'avoir raison
trop tôt
mais le fait de continuer à baisser les
impôts dans un pays où les prélèvements
obligatoires sont à taux un des plus
importants de l'union européenne ne
paraît pas criminel ou fautif dès lors
que encore une fois tout cela et est
menée dans le temps de manière
raisonnable et financé alors l'autre
point pour soutenir la croissance c'est
bien sûr les réformes de structure qui
se réclament également par bruxelles
domicile et on en parle aujourd'hui à
paris que jamais la loi elle comrie la
loi sur le travail la réforme du code du
travail
est ce que est ce que vous comprenez les
débats qui sont nées autour de la de
cette loi est ce que vous comprenez les
différentes modifications qui ont été
faits oui bien sûr je les comprends je
n'ai plus à me prononcer là dessus on
est un iman du gouvernement ni
parlementaire devrait faire là aussi
quelques réflexions j'allais dire de bon
sens je crois un pour la france une
réforme du marché du travail est
absolument indispensable quand le marché
du travail est rigide compte ne peut ni
entrer ni en sortir
on se trouve devant ce qu'on appelle un
marché travail d'insider qui est bloquée
et le chômage ne recule pas c'est la
raison c'est la raison pour cela c'est
la raison pour laquelle tous les pays
qui ont fait des réformes du marché du
travail voient leur chômage baisser
manière importante gelée soulignait ce
matin et tous les pays qui ne l'ont pas
fait
sont dans des conditions beaucoup plus
serré en termes de régions du chômage et
si on peut baisser le chômage il faut
une réponse moi je travaille
deuxième chose est juste pour vous dire
que je comprends les débats qui ont été
posées la commission n'est pas une
commission ultralibérale qui propose
deux tours dérégulé nous disons
flexsécurité ça veut dire de la
flexibilité mais aussi de la sécurité et
notamment la protection des travailleurs
par rapport aux dégâts du chômage et il
faut veiller à cela dans toute
négociation dans toute discussion
parlementaire
enfin il est toujours mieux qu'une
réforme soit accepté par des partenaires
sociaux soutenu par les partenaires
sociaux pour le reste c'est maintenant
la discussion parlementaire de trouver
son équilibre
ce que je souhaite moi ce que je
souhaite c'est qu'en toute hypothèse
cette discussion parlementaire comme l'a
dit le premier ministre aille à son
terme parce que une réforme du marché du
travail je vais pas me prononcer sur le
point final est un signal très attendu à
la fois par les partenaires économiques
et par les partenaires européens
alors deux questions religieuses plus
elle permet de répondre aux différents
critères que j'évoquais plus elle est
capable de permettre d entrer
je marchais le travail meilleure elle
sera deux questions liées à l'actualité
du style la première d'ailleurs lié à ce
qu'on vient d'évoquer la contestation de
la loi travail qui est fustigé dans la
rue un commune
agression social sur la radicalisation
avec son lot de violence écouter ce que
dit olivier besancenot c'est pour ça que
mon problème c'est pas tant les forces
de l'ordre mon vrai problème il est
politique c'est la stratégie du
gouvernement
je crois qu'il ya une tentative de oued
de stigmatiser de diviser le mouvement
et puis de faire peur aux gens alors
qu'on est encore très nombreux parce que
le mouvement tient une tentative de
faire peur aux gens
qu'est ce que je vois même pas de quoi
il s'agit et fans pour le coup je je
suis un français qui travaillent à
bruxelles qui est complètement engagé
dans mon activité mais je suis aussi un
citoyen français quand je vois les
casseurs je me mets à la place des
français dont je suis un français je me
dis que c'est absolument inacceptable et
qu'il n'y a qu'une attitude pas pour aux
casseurs c'est la fermeté une fermeté
respectueuse des droits fondamentaux
notamment des droits de manifester il
faut pas confondre les manifestants et
les casseurs je trouve que l'attitude de
bernard cazeneuve
en l'occurrence et l'attitude juste de
permettre qu'on manifeste permettre
qu'on s'exprime mais aussi d'être sans
aucune forme d'indulgence avec ceux qui
cassent et parce qu'il casse aussi la
confiance qu'on peut avoir dans le
modèle républicain
la sécurité ça fait partie des droits
fondamentaux
autre question dans l'actualité c'est le
salaire du pdg de renault toujours au
coeur des polémiques il donc il a été
augmenté malgré le vote des actionnaires
le président du medef pierre gattaz se
dit gêné et tout à l'heure emmanuel
macron à envisager une loi moi j'ai pas
de problème je dirais avec le montant
j'ai un petit problème avec le fait que
les actionnaires ont voté contre je
dirais les conditions de cette
amélioration et que quelques dix minutes
ou un quart d'heure après le conseil
d'aministration entérine quand même la
rémunération donc là c'est vrai que je
suis un peu gêné par la procédure qui
consiste ce soir un peu sur la vie de
des actionnaires quand justement des
dirigeants d'entreprise aujourd'hui ne
prennent pas leurs responsabilités quand
des gouvernances sont défaillantes
parce qu'elles pensent que tout est
permis et qu'il n'ya plus le
comportement en responsabilité en
éthique on est obligé de rouvrir
des sujets comme celui de la loi je suis
d'accord et ce que dit emmanuel macron
quand j'étais moi même me disais que mes
des finances la question s'était posée
de savoir s'il fallait ou pas légiférer
nous étions interrogés lentement et
j'avais dit à l'époque qu'il fallait une
autorégulation exigeantes c'est à dire
l'application d'un certain nombre de
codes de règles prévues par le medef et
que si cela ne fonctionnait pas il
faudrait légiférer et donc il revient
longuement français de voir maintenant
si ça fonctionne que si ça ne fonctionne
pas je note que président du medef
lui-même se déclarent gênés
ce qui veut dire que les règles ne sont
pas parfaitement satisfaisante
il est souhaitable qu'on en arrive à
trouver un bon équilibre dans le cadre
des règles existantes
si ça n'est pas le cas alors oui il faut
sans doute faudrait-il modifier les
règles merci beaucoup lui c'est le
troisième parti de preuves par 3
maintenant avec perrine tarneaud de
public sénat qui arrivent pour évoquer
avec vous la situation politique de
françois hollande françois hollande qui
a convoqué aujourd'hui les mânes de la
gauche en ce 80e anniversaire du front
populaire je le disais tout à l'heure
mais peut-il encore l'incarner quand
sentiment de trahison semble dominer un
les électeurs de votre quand on écoute
d'abord le chef de l'état tout à l'heure
à la mi-journée il s'inscrit dans le
grand mouvement de la gauche au pouvoir
l'oeuvre transformatrice est
impressionnante
elle fait d'ailleurs pas autant discuter
qu'il y paraît la preuve c'est qu'une
grande partie de ce qui a été fait dans
cette histoire n'a jamais été défait et
puis il y à une donnée qui unit
l'ensemble de ces périodes pourtant d'un
site dadis circonstances très
différentes
c'est que jamais la gauche n'a été
appelé à la direction du pays sans qu'il
ait été lui même saisi de grandes
difficultés intérieures ou extérieures
et parfois parler d'eux bonsoir père et
d'arnaud alors vos questions à pierre
moscovici
t je le rappelle a rencontré françois
hollande hier alors est ce un homme de
gauche
mais est-ce que invoqué donc le front
populaire c'est se donner un peu une
caution de gauche pour françois hollande
au moment on l'accuse
et vous c'est surtout rappeler quelque
chose d'historique nous sommes au 80e
anniversaire de la première expérience
de gauche ont participé des socialistes
dans ce pays et qu'il ya des leçons à
retenir la première leçon est très
simple c'est que hors de l'unité de la
gauche il n'y a pas d'accès au pouvoir
la deuxième leçon c'est qu'il faut aussi
une cohérence intellectuelle et
idéologique qui tiennent compte des
leçons du réel car sinon on se fracasse
sur ce mur qui a été le mur de l'argent
à l'époque et qui est le mur de la
réalité
et chaque fois que la gauche a fait des
réformes qui sont restés mais chaque
fois que la gauche a voulu faire des
réformes qui se heurtait au réel à ce
moment là il était obligé de reculer et
donc il faut éviter de se renier ça
c'est la troisième leçon et on a besoin
aujourd'hui on a besoin c'est logique
social-démocrate d'un réformisme qu'ils
soient ancrés dans le réel talent
réformiste qui soit également européen
mais d'un réformisme tous vos amis du
parti socialiste sans doute sans doute
mais c'est aussi c'est aussi renoncer
aux valeurs de gauche je ne sais pas qui
dit cela vous le dire vous allez me dire
parce que je suis moi vos amis j'ai ce
grand privilège vous aime pas être tous
les jours dans les débats le parti
socialiste et skeleton d'avoir trop
swire de ce quinquennat père moscovici
août et non ceux qui expriment des
opinions ils ne votent pas les textes
qui est compliqué pour une majorité
en même temps ils ne représentent pas
les l'immense majorité des socialistes
et des sociaux-démocrates les ce
quinquennat est un quinquennat dont il
appartient au président de la république
de démontrer qu'il a été utile et puis
ensuite on verra comment cela se portent
de la campagne électorale
vous venez bien les accusations il me
semble je m'exprime personnel que les
explique les accusations de trahison ou
de renoncement sont sans fondement et
que ce n'est pas une façon au sein de la
gauche de mener le débat
non vous ne comprenez pas que certains
puissent être heurtée du fait que
françois hollande se soit éloigné à ce
point par exemple du discours du bourget
on le cite souvent de proposer parfois
des des lois finalement qui satisfont
plus la droite que la gauche l'a long
travail par exemple
au départ elle a quand même plus étaient
applaudis sur les bandes à droite plus
applaudis par le comprenez moi moi de là
je suis une position un peu
inconfortable ce que je suis commissaire
européen je ne peux me faire ni le
critique ni l'avocat mais je n'ai pas
envie je n'ai pas envie et je ne peux
pas je dirais simplement ce que je crois
sur le plan des principes
je pense que une gauche de
transformation qu'une gauche de réformes
qu une gauche dure et elle qu'une gauche
européenne qu'une gauche
sociale-démocrate qu'une jauge rénové et
bien l'avenir pour cette famille
politique qu'elle a besoin de rester
elle même qu'elle a besoin de rester
authentique qu'elles vont rester fidèle
à ses valeurs qu'elle a besoin aussi de
tenir compte du réel est-ce que cela
s'est passé pendant ces cinq ans je
pense que honnêtement il ya eu une
tentative sincère pour le faire avec de
vrais résultats avec de vraies réformes
qu'il ya sans doute eu aussi des choses
qui n'ont pas fonctionné qu'il faut
faire cet examen prémices à donner un
certain nombre d'exemples jeu pour en
donner d'autres prises en a plus qu'on a
abandonné mais ce n'est pas à moi de le
faire encore mais ce qu'on à l'heure du
bilan c'est vrai que manuel valls a
pointé un certain nombre d'erreurs dans
le bon sens avec une campagne électorale
est proche c'est ce moment privilégié où
il ya cette rencontre avec le pays ce
grand débat où il ya d'une part le bilan
il est nécessaire il nous est fait le
chef de l'état et la majorité c'est
l'opposition mais aussi par le chef
d'état est pas la majorité lui même et
je crois comprendre que françois
hollande réfléchit aussi lui même à ce
qui a fonctionné et ce qui n'a pas mal
fonctionné
dupuis ya aussi et c'est une deuxième
dimension qui est essentiel c'est la
dimension du projet car inventaire avant
même la fin du quinquennat ou à la fin
du quinquennat
je n'ai pas le sens la sensation quand
je rencontre françois hollande de
trouver quelqu'un need a battu il ne
l'est pas salem combatif il a toujours
été
il sait ce que c'est que la politique il
donne l'expérience et du métier il a
beaucoup de sang froid
mais ce n'est pas non plus un homme
autosatisfaits je pense qu'il est aussi
capable lui même de se dire voilà ça ça
fonctionne et ça ça n'a pas fonctionné
et s'il était candidat il s'est sans
doute que le projet devrait être à la
fois le prolongement de ce qui a été
fait et aussi sans doute un peu
différent ça c'est la preuve
le propre d'un bon politique et je pense
que en toute hypothèse qu'on peut lui
faire beaucoup de critiques la ville
espère des solutions qui se prépare non
mais vous voulez les rencontres je dis
ça je dis simplement que les télés mon
impression que je n'ai pas dû seulement
hier c'est adam kszczot là que je
connais bien depuis 35 ans j'ai été
effectivement le directeur de sa
campagne présidentielle
je ne suis pas son porte parole je ne
sais pas quelles sont ses intentions
mais veulent 2007
mais mon sentiment c'est que c'est un
homme qui est combatif qui est fier de
ce qu'il a fait et qui est aussi un
homme lucide et qui selon m
ridha c'est pas ça vous savez les gars
vous dites on verra comment les choses
tournent pendant la campagne électorale
je voudrais une autre impression plus
aisés comme ça en est sous la vème
république
la logique elle s'est toujours appliqué
et que le président n'aurait plus que
sortant se représente à la fois pour
défendre son bilan et pour porter un
nouveau projet ça ne marche pas toujours
mais n'a pas toujours été réélu beaucoup
évolué notamment à cause du quinquennat
je je je je pense que la logique tout de
même c'est aussi de se donner du temps
et que justement parce qu'il ya le
quinquennal quinquennat pourquoi est il
était fait on pouvait se dire deux fois
sept ans c'est trop et d'ailleurs à part
françois mitterrand personnes a fait
deux fois 7 ans et les dernières années
80 et des années compliquées et donc on
s'est dit le quinquennat pourquoi pas ce
qu'on peut faire deux fois cinq ans
c'est en gros le rythme qui existe dans
nos démocraties donc l'existant du
quinquennat va plutôt renforcé l'idée de
deux candidatures d'un homme à la
présidence de la république s'est
toujours passé le président encore une
fois je ne fais qu'une observation fait
l'historique qui me paraît cohérente que
fait chèrement de nos institutions
sortant est le candidat naturel de son
camp mais lorsqu'elle quand même naturel
je dis simplement que l'expérience
historique oblige il nouveau c'est qu'un
président élu arrive en si mauvaise
posture et un nouveau scrutin et la
jeunesse tourne aussi le dos à françois
hollande c'est un sondage conduit dans
le monde ce soir à sondage de l'ifop et
la rupture semble irréversible marie
noëlle lienemann opposants internes
candidate et une hypothétique primaires
de la gauche réagit et commente la
gauche n'est pas au rendez vous des
attentes des gens eh ben les gens
semblaient s'en écarte c'est vrai des
couches populaires
dix ouvriers du monde du travail ça
devient vrai pour la jeunesse oui c'est
catastrophique
oui il faut un sursaut faut que la
gauche retrouve ses fondamentaux et soit
en même temps gauche contemporaine qui
abordent des sujets d'aujourd'hui sur
doucement sans renoncer à son débat
est-ce que vous avez jamais beaucoup
aimé ça je vais pas commencer maintenant
mais ce que vous estimez comme manuel
valls qui est aujourd'hui deux gauches
irréconciliables
non je pense que il y a des gauches qui
aujourd'hui ont beaucoup de points
d'écart ya d'une part une gauche qui est
en effet ancré dans le réel d'une gauche
réformiste une gauche européenne et une
gauche plus radicale qui parfois fait à
l'autre le procès en renoncements que
vous évoquez mais non elle ne perd pas
étrangers ne peuvent pas être récupérés
considérant leur dialogue est difficile
mais comme je le rappelais on parle du
front populaire il ya un talisman qui
est vraiment indispensable dans
l'existence de la gauche c'est l'unité
si les gauches sont irréconciliables
alors il n'y a plus de capacités pour la
gauche a accédé unitems on n'arrête pas
d'entendre des socialistes les télés
mais nous avons délaissé les autres nous
avons aussi aussi vous avez aussi un
système qui est favori cela c'est le
système de l'élection à deux tours en
france avec un mode de scrutin qui n'est
pas la proportionnelle on peut on peut
ne pas le critiquer dans la
proportionnelle
on n'a pas ce talisman d'unité on n'a
pas le même fonctionnement
on peut avoir une plus grande
fragmentation on peut avoir des
alliances qui sont plus improbables
certains attendent depuis tellement de
temps qu'il y ait un centre qui se
constitue un gouvernement au centre
c'était l'idée de valéry giscard
d'estaing d'autres dodo d'autres pour
qu'on revienne ainsi combinaisons aux
délices à l'heure de la catherine fait
ses idées de la perche que vous tendez
la perche que vous tendez effectivement
sur l'art en composition politique ni de
gauche ni de droite 1 c'est un peu le
leitmotiv du mouvement marche des
manuels macron qu'en pensez vous moi je
suis gelé dit un homme de gauche je ne
crois pas que l'atténuation
l'affaiblissement ou la fin du clivage
gauche droite soit un progrès pour la
démocratie
on a besoin de capacités d'alternance en
même temps ce que je sais c'est que il
faut aussi être capable de travailler
ensemble que la politique ce n'est pas
une guerre civile
je suis commissaire européen à la
commission européenne nous sommes une
instance politique il ya vingt-huit
commissaire 14 sont des conservateurs
huit sont des socialistes cinq sont des
libéraux il ya un britannique qui par
ailleurs est conservateur mais pas la
même famille que les autres et on trouve
des accords tous les jours mais
attention quand on est dans une
coalition et ça existe sa coalition en
collission ça existe aussi en allemagne
la commission n'est jamais quelque chose
qui précède l'élection elle peut lui
succéder et une coalition n'est pas
quelque chose d'harmonieux hutu safadi
et où tout se confond c'est pas ça c'est
un combat vous parlais tout à l'heure
mais merkel madame merkel un
gouvernement de coalition
ils ont à une charte de coalition les
gens de la cdu ou ne se reconnaissent
pas dans ce que dit le spd les gens du
spd ne se reconnaissent pas dans ce que
dit la cd ou et donc tous les jours ils
s'ajustent ils s'affrontent la coalition
elle peut être obligé si d'aventuré
madame le pen était au 2e tour en 2010
est certes un sondage beaucoup de
sondages en réalité le 10 à l'heure à ce
moment il serait compliqué pour ceux qui
auraient élu un président deuxième tour
de dire on s'ignore
mais ce serait le résultat de l'élection
et ce serait forcément un combat ça ne
peut pas être une confusion qui précède
l'élection
c'est en tout cas une hypothèse et
l'apathie emmanuel macron manuel valls
dit aussi un peu les mêmes choses que
son ministre que je laime là
je ne veux pas les départager mais ils
ne disent pas tout à fait la même chaîne
jean christophe cambadélis et les partis
disent pas la même chose ne disent pas
la même chose disent pas la même chose
parce que là dit voilà ni droite ni
gauche ont fait quelque chose avant
c'est le sens de son mouvement
l'audi je suis de gauche et je peux être
amené à travailler avec d'autres dans le
cas d'une coalition ce qui est déjà plus
classique
nous verrons cambadélis a dépassé aussi
les partis politiques en toute hypothèse
que ce qui est important et ça c'est ma
position constante c'est que la gauche
aurait neuf il ya évidemment une
satisfaction par rapport à la gauche en
france il ya besoin de modernisation
il ya besoin de théories macro il ya
besoin d'un il ya besoin de théoriser ce
qui a été fait il ya un besoin de
conceptualiser il ya besoin d'avancer
dans la gauche par rapport à l'europe de
n'être enfin complètement européen et de
construire également une europe qui soit
davantage marqué par les idées de la
gauche de faire des propositions socio
démocrates mais j'y travaille moi avec
martin schulz le président du parlement
européen avec matteo renzi et donc voilà
je crois plus que notre avenir c'est la
modernisation de la gauche
la refondation de la gauche la
rénovation de la gauche que la fa 10
mans de la gauche ou la fin de la gauche
assène françois hollande qu'elle incarne
ça on verra je sais pas je sais c'est
pas à moi de le dire
je dis simplement que quand je vois le
président la république je vois un homme
combatif et quand vous entendez nicolas
sarkozy dire de toute façon il y aura
alternance c'est inévitable en 2017 il
se trompe vous qui avez eu des mots très
durs pour l'ancien président de la
république il y aura alternance
un jour c'est ça mais les pontes de
démocratie et françois hollande lui lui
répond que l'alternance n'est pas
inévitable
on verra et on verra qui sera candidat
en 2017 pour la gauche
et pour la droite nous avons choisi
nicolas sarkozy on verra aussi si
l'alternance existe au sein des
républicains d'accord vous aimeriez que
le match soit rejoué en 2010 franchement
c'est pas à moi de choisir
il ya des instances qui sont prévues
pour ça il y aura des primaires à droite
elles seront pas ce qu'on passait
finalement la commission
elles seront passionnantes il y aura à
gauche une modalité de sélection du
choix du candidat vous êtes membre de la
commission européenne vous l'avez
rappelé qu'ils prônent des efforts
budgétaires des réformes de structure de
votre candidat c'est le candidat de
droite
j'ai pas du tout l'impression d'être
devenu un homme de droite en étant la
commission européenne tout à l'heure par
exemple on parlait des déficits
la commission européenne et j'en ai fait
la proposition à une approche qui
introduit des flexibilités dans le pacte
de stabilité et de croissance qui prend
donc mieux en compte l'arrêt classement
les réformes structurelles ou encore les
efforts faits pour la sécurité ou pour
l'accueil de réfugiés
non moi je suis un commissaire de gauche
qui bâtit des compromis avec d'autres
qui le sont moins
j'accepte les compromis mais j'essaie
toujours de les pousser dans le sens des
progressistes parce que pour moi à
progressistes c'est un homme de gauche
oh merci merci beaucoup pierre moscovici
d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation merci perrine pensons à
tous et la semaine prochaine notre
invité sera un réformiste tient le même
sénateur maire de lyon gérard collomb à
la semaine prochaine